la primavera árabe nació aquí 17 de
diciembre de 2010
mohamed buazizi se inmola en sidi bouzid
para denunciar la confiscación de su
carro de frutas y verduras por parte de
la policía un acto desesperado que
rápidamente encendió a todo el país
liderados por la juventud los tunecinos
se levantaron contra el presidente zín
el abidín ben alí y su régimen
autoritario de 24 años responsables
según ellos del desempleo la corrupción
y la violencia policial
el 14 de enero de 2011 la calle de
triunfo ben alí huyó a arabia saudita la
revolución estaba en marcha con ella una
sed inédita de libertad y democracia
para pasar de una dictadura a una
democracia se necesita un periodo
difícil al menos no hubo muertos y
heridos formadas en octubre de 2011 el
partido islamista enahda ganó las
primeras elecciones libres organizadas
desde 1956 deseoso de poner a la sharia
la ley islámica en el centro de la nueva
constitución pero en 2014 un acuerdo
entre diferentes grupos políticos empujó
a la formación a dejar el poder el campo
secular ganó luego la nueva constitución
fue adoptada por una gran mayoría
en diciembre beyi caíd essebsi se
convirtió en el primer presidente
tunecino elegido democráticamente se
mantuvo en el cargo hasta su muerte en
julio de 2019 dejó atrás la imagen de un
líder progresista apegado al carácter
secular del estado diez años después de
la revolución de los jazmines la mayoría
de las reformas e inversiones prometidas
particularmente en el área de
infraestructura siguen siendo letra
muerta para muchos en la esperanza ha
dado paso a la desilusión
sólo queda el lema trabajo libertad y
dignidad nacional esto es lo que
escuchamos durante la revolución pero
nada se materializó sobre ellas
una situación económica agravada por el
hobbit 19 el sector turístico clave está
aún más golpeado por los ataques
terroristas según el fm y se espera que
la tasa de crecimiento de túnez se
contraiga un 7% en 2020